Okay. I want to add one more piece to our URL's. And
that's called a fragment. A fragment is separated from the rest of
the URL by a hash sign. A fragment is generally used
to reference a particular part of the page you are looking at.
There are other fancier uses if you're, if you're going to do
some complex JavaScript things. But for our purposes, it's just there. And
all I really want you to know is that when you
see it in the URL, it is not sent to the server
when you make a request. The fragment purely exists in
the browser. If we had a URL with both queries and
a fragment, I'll show you how that looks. When there are
query parameters, the fragment follows the query parameters. It comes last.